こんにちわ
違う、なんかなんかなんか変
挨拶やだな、なんか。じゃあ新しい挨拶考えてください！
ちょっと、コメント欄に新しい挨拶考えてください。
僕も今度からちゃんと新しい挨拶をね
というわけで、こんにちわ。はじめしゃちょーです。
皆さんは、お酢と胃薬、知ってますか？
お酢と胃薬ってことなんですけども、まぁこちらがお酢ですね。
まぁ一般家庭のＢＢＡ・・・あッ。一般家庭のお姉さん方が良く使ってるやつと
こちらが胃薬です。セルベールとガストールっていうやつです。
とりあえず２種類買ってきたんですけどもぉ・・・
ちょっとね、ちょある（ペシッ！！）
ちょっとね、とある情報によるとお酢と胃薬を混ぜると、「爆発する」っていう話を聞きました。
ちょっと怪しいな、うん。ちょっとどころじゃない！相当怪しいけども
ちょっとね俺も怪しいと思ったし、ないと思いました。
けど！意外とね、ありかもしれないって僕の考えです。意外とありかもしれないです。
なぜかというとですね、そもそも胃薬ってどこに入ると思いますか？
そう！胃だよな？
そう。体の中の胃に入るわけなんだけども
胃の中には何があるでしょう？
★ＳＯＵ★
胃酸です。
胃酸、酸、酸性だよ。あのモノを溶かす酸があるわけなんですよ
で↑な↑
でもねなんか、ガストールってガスをこうなんかするんですよ。
ガスをなんかする
その酸の中にこれを入れて、ガスをこうなんかするですよ。たぶん。
だから、ガスでしょ！
で、酸の中に入れて、これがガスが反応する。
それでこれもね、お酢ってみんな知らないと思うけど、たぶん「酸性」なんですよ。
これも酸なので、ひょっとしてね、これがね胃酸とちょっと相互関係があって
こう胃袋での爆発的反応を、ひょっとすると、この胃薬とお酢だけでできるかもしれないっていう
僕の考え★ＤＥ★ＳＵ★
俺もちょっとよくわかんないんだけど、ワンチャンあるで、これはワンチャンある。
ひょっとしたら大爆発するかもしれない。
じゃあ早速、やってみましょう！
爆発パターン基本信じてないんですけど、ほんとになるかどうかわかんないやつだけやりますからね。
粒タイプと粉タイプの２種類があるんですけど
まずは、まぁガストール怪しいんでガス発生しそうなんで、ガストール後にしましょう。
さきにこのセルベールからいきます。
えっ。待ってなんか怖くなって来た・・・
怖くなってきちゃった( ;∀;)
ちょっと怖い
（置いてかないではじめ・・・）
えぇ、大丈夫だよね？割とビビってる俺は。
まずは胃薬を入れましょう。爆発したらまぁ動画的には嬉しいよ。動画的には嬉しいけど
一個人的には・・・すごい、いやです。
よし、粉入れました。
ちょっと待って怖いよぉ、ホントに怖いよぉ
じゃあ酢入れましょう！
これを入れて爆発したら、動画的には美味しいが俺は
わりと、わりと怖いからね！！
３・２・１
あれ・・・
ＯＫです！粉は多分大丈夫でした！
ちょっと、内心ホッとした自分とガックリした自分がいます。
じゃあ次はね、次は！！次はガストールでやります。
これはね、わかんないですよ。
もうガスって書いてあるから、多分こっちがメインでしょうね。
先に酢から入れよう。
ゥプッ
というわけでお酢を入れました。
ではガストールで、爆発するかどうかやってみましょう！
３・２・１ッ！！
うわっ、反応してるでも。
反応してる！反応してる！反応してるぞ！
えっ、怖い・・・反応はしてる！えっ何？反応はしてる！反応はしてる！
めっちゃ泡出てる！わかるかな・・・めっちゃ泡出てるんですよ
えっ・・・これ爆発感？爆発感ある？これ。
爆発感は・・・
爆発感はないかもしれない
どうやら・・・デマだったようですね。
それでは皆さん、次回の動画でお会いしましょう。